ja seit einiger Zeit diskutieren wir
kontrovers das Thema Kinder kriegen ich
will mich eigentlich nicht trennen von
ihm ja ich drehe mich im Kreis ne oh
mein Gott
[Musik]
mein geliebtes ungeborenes Kind leider
haben wir uns niemals kennengelernt
das ist ja schon auch eine große Angst
die ich jetzt habe
[Musik]
wo solche Momente werden die einzigen
die ich feiern würde
es geht hier ab
[Musik]
willst du Kinder ja vielleicht nein oh
ganz ganz eindeutig auf vielleicht
begründet sich halt weitestgehend da
drin dass ich mir nicht sicher bin ob
ich die Verantwortung die es heißt wenn
man ein Kind bekommt tragen möchte und
auch tragen kann ich bin in der Mitte
bei vielleicht Tendenz runterzuneien
homosexuell jetzt im Vergleich zu
heterosexuellen Paaren sind die Hürden
deutlich höher als ich kann noch nicht
sagen ob es klappt aber stand heute ja
willst du Kinder ja also definitiv
irgendwann ist es dann zu spät und das
will ich verhindern deswegen ja möchte
ich mit an sie immer besprechen also da
steht nicht wann und ja also das Feiern
kommt jetzt und das Kind kommt später
erhoffe mir von heute dass ich
vielleicht so ein minimal gewissenhaft
oder das Gefühl dafür habe es zu wollen
oder nicht zu wollen
[Musik]
schwanger sein für mich ist eine
komplette horror-vorstellung das ist
einfach nur Sorge und eine Verantwortung
die so stressig für mich klingt und für
mich ist ich möchte meine Energie
einfach fokussieren auf mich und auf das
nahe Umfeld was ich besitze ich bin Quan
ich bin 27 Jahre ich bin Erzieherin
studiere soziale Arbeit und ich möchte
keine Kinder kriegen
aus
das ist eine Entscheidung mit der habe
ich mich sehr lange auseinandergesetzt
und mit der habe ich mich beschäftigt
ich habe die gut überlegt ich habe mich
ausgetauscht mit Menschen die mir nahe
stehen
ich komme aus einem ziemlich kleinen
Dorf da ist das ja ein bisschen stärker
vertreten man macht ab wie man hat einen
festen Partner seit man 16 ist man baut
ein Haus man hat Kinder man heiratet so
Bob das ist das Leben was man möchte was
man was auch so die Gesellschaft von
einem verlangt kommen auch aus einem
kleinen Dorf auf der Schwäbischen Alb
und genauso ist es ich bin dann auch
direkt ausgebrochen und bin nach dem
Abitur nach Amerika habe dort anderthalb
Jahre als Au-pair Nanny gearbeitet wow
like weiß
also ja das habe ich genauso wie sie im
Lebenslauf danach habe ich die
Ausbildung gemacht zu Erzieherin mag
einfach die Arbeit mit kleinen Kindern
mir gibt es sehr viel ich kann da viel
geben und dann habe ich mich nach der
Ausbildung noch mal entschieden noch mal
irgendwie wegzugehen und wenn er nach
Australien wo ich dann direkt mich um
Neugeborenes gekümmert habe
also ich habe mich schon sehr als die
zweite Mutter gefühlt weil das Kind war
sehr viel bei mir noch mal übers
Wochenende alleine und das ist ein
schönes Gefühl gebraucht zu werden ja
dann habe ich erfahren dass ich selbst
schwanger war
das war nicht direkt oh Gott jetzt werde
ich Mutter jetzt trage ich ein Kind in
mir sondern das war für mich in dem
Moment einfach nur ein Fakten und wenn
ich dann genau hatten hatte ich einen
Schwangerschaftsabbruch
okay
was geht hier ab
das heißt sie hat abgetrieben oder was
zu dem Zeitpunkt war das für uns
eigentlich eine sehr einstimmige
Entscheidung dass wir das für uns so
nicht möchten
[Applaus]
ich finde Abtreibung unfassbar bitter
ich kenne auch Freundinnen die die vor
Jahren abgetrieben hat haben und die
heute sagen ach heute wäre sie zehn
Jahre alt oder so ich würde behaupten
dass ich sehr sicher bin dass ich
ebenfalls einen Schwangerschaftsabbruch
durchführen würde wenn ich heute die
Nachrichten käme dass ich schwanger wäre
einfach weil ich mich nicht immer noch
nicht in der Lage befinde diese
Verantwortung auf mich zu nehmen also
ich glaube schon dass ich eine gute
Mutter wäre und das habe ich natürlich
auch in meiner Arbeit als Nanny in der
Familie zurückbekommen sonst werden die
Kinder ja hätten die nicht so ein
inniges Verhältnis mit mir gehabt aber
ich möchte es einfach nicht
ich will nicht immer diese Angst haben
oh Gott was ist mit den Kindern wenn ich
das und das mache wo können die hin oder
wie kriege ich die gut unter das ist
einfach nur Sorge und eine
[Musik]
Verantwortung die so stressig für mich
klingt und für mich ist das da da
verstehe ich sie echt also von der Seite
habe ich jetzt nicht betrachtet die
ständige Angst um die Kinder das ist das
ein unglaubliches Gefühl ist also ich
kriege das ja immer noch mit wenn ich
verreise soll ich immer noch schreiben
ich bin gut angekommen
das ist egoistisch
ja kann man so sehen das ist egoistisch
aber
man kann ja auch sagen dass es
egoistisch Kinder zu kriegen
Inflation
Klimakrise all die Dinge die dieser Welt
Schmerz und dann zu sagen ja aber ich
kriege jetzt ein Kind weil das gehört
halt irgendwie dazu ohne vielleicht
daran zu denken ja aber was ist denn
vielleicht in 20 Jahren wie sieht es
dann dann aus kann man vielleicht auch
sagen dass es egoistisch
das ist auf jeden Fall ein großer Punkt
über den ich mir Gedanken mache ja ob
wenn ich dann ein Kind bekäme ich eine
richtige Antwort hätte wenn das Kind
dann fragt hey guck mal ich bin hier so
du wusstest Du gebärst mich in einer
scheiß Welt so und zwar die völlig egal
auf der anderen Seite war es natürlich
immer so dass die Menschheit von
Katastrophen heimgesucht wurden dass wir
Kriege hatten sobald du den richtigen
Partner hast änderst du deine Meinung ja
den Satz habe ich schon sehr oft gehört
auch gerade am Wochenende auch schon
gehört wir haben uns damit sehr früh
auseinandergesetzt weil klar in der
Partnerschaft muss man gucken ob die
eigenen Ziele irgendwie zusammenpassen
und Vorstellungen fürs Leben irgendwo
glaube ich dass da was dran um ehrlich
zu sein weil
ich glaube sobald man sich halt
irgendwie wirklich sicher und geborgen
in einer Partnerschaft führt hat man
vielleicht dann eben auch diese diese
Zweifel ob es nicht an der Zeit ist oder
ob es nicht doch einfach dazugehört
diese Angst alleine zu sein die habe ich
gar nicht man hat ja immer Leute um sich
rum
werde erstmal älter also ich denke mir
wie alt soll ich noch werden um selbst
entscheiden zu dürfen was ich will und
was ich nicht will
aber interessant hut ab ich meine die 27
da kann sie noch was tun in den nächsten
zehn Jahren Shemale
und ich glaube da sollte auch nichts von
außen irgendwie kommen und ihr sagen so
hey denk doch mal drüber nach nein wenn
dann müsste das von ihr kommen ganz
einfach
[Musik]
auf meiner kontralistisch steht ja ganz
oben eben Verantwortung Fragezeichen
Ausrufezeichen
[Musik]
kann was ich will ich würde diese
Freiheit nicht aufgeben wollen für eine
Familie das bezieht sich jetzt auch auf
Partnerinnen
unabhängig bleiben an erster Stelle
ja also trifft voll zu ich hätte gedacht
dass die wirtschaftliche Unsicherheit
ganz oben steht
also gerade bei uns Stehtisch
Beschäftigten oder bei freischaffenden
Künstlerinnen und Künstlern durch das
immer wieder eben
die Sorge ich kann mein Kind nicht mehr
füttern aber was mir noch ins Auge
spring ist tatsächlich kein Bezug zu
Kindern das erstaunt mich also wir haben
die keine Verwandtschaft kriegen die
sonst durch Freunde keinen Kontakt zu
Kindern also das ist das ist
erschreckend wo leben die vielleicht
würde ich nur Krieg und Konflikte quasi
auf Platz drei schieben und dann Angst
vor Überforderung wenn ich jetzt aber
ein Kind 24 Stunden bei mir hätte und
dafür verantwortlich wäre dann fällt dir
diese Angst vor Überforderung eigentlich
nie weg
[Musik]
möchtest du
mein geliebtes ungeborenes Kind leider
haben wir uns niemals kennengelernt ich
bin Benedikt und ich wäre so gerne dein
Vater gewesen doch es hat nicht geklappt
ich bin unfruchtbar du wärest vermutlich
heute neun oder zehn Jahre alt und du
wärest unser ganzer Stolz der deine
Mutter und mir wir sind seit 18 Jahren
glücklich zusammen du wärst das perfekte
kleine Wunder natürlich hätten wir
anfangs Angst gehabt vor der großen
Verantwortung was auch einer der Gründe
war warum wir so lange mit dem
Kinderkriegen gewartet haben
doch dann war es zu spät heute weiß ich
dass man einen solchen Wunsch nicht
aufschieben sollte das Kinder einfach
zum Leben dazugehören so schwer ist
einem vorkommt sie groß zu ziehen ich
bin selbst nur ein Mann von vielen die
zeugungsunfähig sind es gibt eine große
Dunkelziffer und die Forschung weiß noch
immer nicht warum das so ist ich werde
niemals mit dir spielen dich in die Luft
heben oder dir einfach nur Sachen
erklären können obwohl ich das so gerne
mache und ich hoffe dass Menschen die
Kinder bekommen können und Zweifel haben
intensiv darüber nachdenken ob sie es
nicht doch wagen sollten denn das durch
das wir gehen mussten wünsche ich
niemandem dein Benedikt wow
ja sehr bedrückend
zu
also nicht dass er zu lange gewartet hat
da gab es sicher Gründe aber eben das
Kinder zum Leben dazugehören ja schon
hart ich will gar nicht daran denken
eigentlich ja das sind ja die die
Gedanken die er jetzt wunderschön
formuliert die ich auch immer habe eben
wird man das mal bereuen
boah
ich frag mich gerade selber wenn ich
dann sage hey wegen deiner Karriere hast
du es nicht getan
hast jetzt zwar Kohle aber kein Kind
[Musik]
ich will auf jeden Fall ein Kind haben
das ist kein Thema
und ja wenn ich mir jetzt vorstellen
würde was ich vermissen würde wenn ich
keinen haben könnte
ja wie ich schon gesagt habe das trifft
mich einfach so dieses diese
bedingungslose Liebe die Kinder strahlen
diese spielerisch und diese Spaß dieses
Lachen
trotzdem ähm habe ich halt das Gefühl
dass es eben eine unglaublich
romantisierte
Art und Weise ist sich Elternschaft
vorzustellen künstliche Befruchtung
Adoption Pflegeeltern schafft dass er
alles Möglichkeiten die dann vielleicht
auch im Betracht kommen würden
ich würde jetzt nicht erzwingen die
Leihmutterschaft das was mich am meisten
oder was für mich am meisten für uns am
meisten in Frage kommt
und wo ich einfach dann meine eigenen
Gene auch weitergeben kann und ich bin
total neugierig natürlich wie es wäre
ein Mini zu sehen
aber das ist der letzte der allerletzte
Grund für mich
so schon das Bild oh Gott Albtraum
aber ich stelle mir vor wie schön das
ist ich glaube beide wissen wofür sie
das alles tun bis jetzt kurz nach 7 Uhr
und ich nehme euch jetzt mal mit auf
eine Reise mit mir und den Jungs also
ich bin unglaublich stark geworden durch
meine Mutter werden es gibt ja auch
nicht den perfekten Zeitpunkt um Kinder
zu haben
ich bin Anita ich bin 35 und Mama von
vier Söhnen und Mama sein ist für mich
die Erfüllung des Lebens bin 35 Jahre
alt und für mich ist Vater sein eines
der größten Abenteuer meines Lebens soll
[Musik]
zusammen haben wir vier Söhne den Julius
der 7 Moritz und Alexander die Zwillinge
sind fünf und der lukas ist zwei
jetzt startet Mission Küche ich habe ja
gesagt für uns ist immer ziemlich aus
du sagst Mission Küche ey das ist da
brauche ich eine Woche für was in
Ordnung zu bringen ich würde da alleine
verzweifeln ich bräuchte dich dafür also
morgens geht es dann schon von 0 auf 100
der eine will zu spielen
dann fliegt die Milch um und dann ist
der Boden nass und wenn wir da nicht
hingucken dann geht's ab
sofort diese fehlende Ruhe aufgefallen
ja das schreckt mich auch so ein
bisschen ab wir wollen Verteilung ist
ist schon so dass dass ich eigentlich
eher so für die Bespaßung der Kinder
verantwortlich bin aber unsere Kinder
sind halt sehr große Mama Babys
doch eher so dieses fürsorgliche und
dieses ich bin halt eher so die
kümmererin ich will lieber die Bespaßung
machen so nö kein Bock auf Küche und
kein Bock auf nur Zähne putzen und
Socken anziehen und so nee
die Zähne nicht putzen
und gerade muss ich sagen
weil früher war das immer so mein Putz
und Aufräumen Tag und danach war alles
schön und jetzt ist es tatsächlich mein
Chaos Tag weil wir einfach überhaupt
keine Struktur haben
solche Momente werden die einzigen die
ich feiern würde
es Prügelei Kinder haben halt einfach
eine sehr süße stumpfe Art manchmal die
Welt und die Realität zu beschreiben und
das sind Gold Momente solche Momente so
jetzt sind wir draußen ich bin richtig
leichter dass sie alle raus sind weil
die Sonne kommt nämlich jetzt auch
gerade und das ist meistens immer so die
beste Möglichkeit
Team heißt wirklich jeden Tag sich zu
organisieren und ja Möglichkeiten zu
finden dass das für jeden irgendwie geht
der micha hat mich gefragt ob ich mit
nach Köln möchte was ist da
können es ja eine Nacht
für mich drei Tage
in Köln sind doch die Biere kleine
Schatz
es wird schön bearbeitet ne es wird
schön belabert ach komm so dann sind
doch für mich so eher die Standard
Rollen die da so eingenommen werden und
das auch nicht so ist nicht so wirklich
keine verfechteren Freunde
ein bisschen schade dass du Männer also
so ist bei uns ist so dürfen irgendwie
abends einfach mal länger weg bleiben
ich als Frau ich muss irgendwie immer
alles strategisch planen also wenn ich
mal abzweck will oder in meinen Freunden
treffen möchte dann muss ich immer
Schlafanzüge hinrichten Abendessen
kochen bis in Terminal eintragen
mal kurz eine WhatsApp komm heut später
ja für mich ist das ein no go
ich vermisse manchmal diese die was er
hat diese Freiheit zu sagen ich habe
heute das Bedürfnis mich zu bewegen ich
gehe heute abend noch mal kurz ins Sport
oder Lukas schläft noch und jetzt
genieße ich einfach mal die Ruhe der die
Stille tut einfach den Ohren und im
Körper mal gut ich sag immer meinen
Beruf ist Lehrerin und mein Geschäft ist
Mama sein ich arbeite zwei Tage die
Woche da arbeite ich wirklich von
morgens um 8 Uhr bis dann nachmittags
und das gute ist halt dass wir einfach
viel familiäre Unterstützung hier haben
das macht mir möglich dass ich arbeiten
kann ich bin selbstständig ich habe
Auktionshaus und seitdem ich Kinder habe
weiß ich wirklich dass Zeit unglaublich
kostbar ist also Robert müsst ihr dann
in seine in der Anzahl der Drehtage
zurückstecken das vielleicht dann nicht
mehr
einmal im Monat irgendwo gedreht wird
sondern vielleicht alle drei Monate
jetzt als Beispiel und das würde ich
würde ich dann Erwarten einmal im Monat
ist ja sehr wenig zu drehen aber da
finden wir sicher eine Einigung und
ja ich bin bereit privat auf jeden Fall
zurückzustecken auch in großen Teilen
beruflich
ist es natürlich besonders bitter aber
ja es gehört dazu sein eigenes Leben und
die Karriere müssen zurückstecken ja man
ist fremd bestimmt aber ob sein eigenes
Leben zurückstecken muss sehe ich halt
nicht so sondern früher hat man halt
irgendwas mit dem Partner gemacht und
jetzt macht man eigentlich eher was für
die Kinder oder Partner kommt mit das
habe ich schon sehr oft gehört dass ich
Paare dann nur noch über die Kinder
definieren ich finde man sollte sich
auch die Zeit nehmen für die
Partnerschaft
ja es soll ja nicht irgendwie dann
irgendwann in ein paar Jahren die
Partnerschaft runter leiden für mich
wäre es jetzt nicht so dass
Familie mich gänzlich erfüllen würde wir
sitzen jetzt so schön in der Sonne das
sind so die goldstunden bei uns okay das
Wetter toll ist alle Kinder glücklich
das ist einfach diese bedingungslose
Liebe und das wunderschön ist und dass
ich wirklich jedem Wünsche ab und zu
sagen wir schon wir würden auch mal ein
oder anderen den ein oder anderen
verleihen mal tageweise aber am Ende des
Tages schon alle behalten
also bedingungslose Liebe ich glaube das
ist das schönste von allen und der
Kamera reinstecken was man möchte und
und auch wirklich Mama aus dem letzten
Loch pfeifen es kommt dann einfach
wieder mehr hat vor kurzem einen Freund
gesagt bezogen auf seinen Sohn dass man
jemanden so lieben kann das kannst du
dir nicht vorstellen und das sind schon
Worte finde ich die ja die Genitiv ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen nie wieder
schwanger zu sein das ist aktuell nicht
so dass ich das Gefühl habe aber jetzt
Briefkasten zu gar nicht mehr ich gebe
jetzt ganz viel und hoffe dass ich dann
auch im Alter die Liebe auch ein Stück
weit wieder zurückbekommen
so ein schönes Bild
einfach Liebe pur also würdest du auch
so essen anrichten und Vesper machen und
den Windel wechseln und denen auch die
Schuhe zubinden und eben auch das was
man halt nicht so gerne macht natürlich
Geschrei dieser
nonstoppel
Lärmpegel eigentlich den den man da für
morgens bis abends ausgesetzt ist ich
glaube das ähm es ist schon sehr sehr
anstrengend ich bin aufgewachsen mit
einer alleinerziehende Mutter sie war
sehr aufopferungsvoll uns gegenüber und
das sehe ich für mich auf jeden Fall
nicht also ne dass ich mein ich so in
den Hintergrund Stelle wie sieht es
getan hat was würdest du machen aber
wenn ein Kind nicht auf sich hören will
ja da gibt es irgendwie eine Technik
dass er doch zuhört
[Musik]
die einzig so richtig positive Reaktion
hatte ich als der als der süße Bengel da
ja seinen Witz gemacht hat sage ich mal
also ein gue was in unserer Gesellschaft
zu los ist hat der wenigstens sind
Tausendstel Prozent
mitzugeben kann dass die
Nachfolgegeneration die Werte Teil die
ich für richtig halte dann ist es
natürlich toll
der erste Familie gründen das ist dann
noch mal eine ganz neue Ebene so ein
Schritt zusammen zu wagen ja ein Ziel zu
haben gemeinsam diesen Weg zu gehen
diese Herausforderung zu meistern mein
Kind kriegt damit man nicht alleine ist
im Alter
absolut keine Verbindung zu diesem Satz
das halte ich für egoistisch sie auch
keine Garantie dass mein Kind im Alter
da ist also wenn es ins Ausland sieht
dann ist es weg dann habe ich irgendwie
falsch investiert allerdings finde ich
Leben einen Sinn geben gar nicht so
verkehrt ich glaube einfach mit einem
Kind zu Hause weiß man das was man
gerade tut ist richtig
[Musik]
oh sie schreibt den Brief an ihre
Tochter das finde ich auch also
eigentlich wie bei dem anderen Menschen
finde ich das sehr spannend aber die
kann es ja wirklich lesen an meiner
Tochter wenn du das liest wirst du
erfahren haben dass ich es bereut habe
Mutter geworden zu sein das ist mich
alles an Kraft kostete fremdbestimmt zu
sein dass die fehlende Zeit für mich mit
den Boden unter den Füßen wegzog so sehr
dass ich eines Tages mit dir als Baby
auf dem Schoß Tränen überströmt das hast
und dachte ich will einfach nur weg ich
fühlte mich allein gelassen und
überfordert mir fehlte die Ruhe und
meine Freiheit ich hatte mich für eine
Lebensaufgabe entschieden die mich die
meiste Zeit unglücklicher zurückließ als
zuvor mein Freiheitsdrang macht es mir
schwer die die Mutter zu sein die du
verdient hast doch ich will dass du
weißt meine Reue gilt nicht dir als
Person dein Papa und ich lieben dich
über alles trotzdem spreche ich offen
über meine Reue
und ich hoffe du verstehst warum ich das
tue nicht um andere von Mutter werden
abzuhalten sondern um ihnen eine Chance
zu geben die ich nie hatte informiert zu
sein eine realistische Vorstellung von
dem zu haben was sie erwarten kann um
anderen Betroffenen zu sagen ihr seid
nicht allein in liebe deine Mama
ich finde es sehr mutig dass sie das so
sagt ich glaube viele würden sich das
nicht trauen so weit habe ich jetzt
nicht gedacht dass es halt tatsächlich
so anstrengend sein könnte so sein
ganzes Leben irgendwie umzustellen also
ich finde es eigentlich schön an dem
Brief dass sie sagt ich bereue nicht
dich als Person sondern ich bereue die
Rolle als Mutter wird sich auch nicht
bereuen denke ich mal ein Kind zu haben
aber eben Mutter zu sein also das hängt
natürlich zusammen aber kann man
vielleicht trotzdem irgendwie trennen
kann mir keine Situation vorstellen wo
ich da sitzen sagt hätte ich doch hätten
wir doch nur nicht und ähm hätte ich
damals nicht so Getränken Kind zu
bekommen weil ich jetzt so wie andere
Sachen nicht habe kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen ne
[Musik]
hallo hi wie werdet sind diese Argumente
die ich jetzt gerade für mich habe für
mein zukunfts- ich glaube es ist wichtig
solange kein eindeutiges Ja ich möchte
das gerne Wagen da ist sich ruhig immer
wieder zu überprüfen wie wichtig ist
denn die Mutter als Person kann ein Mann
können zwei Männer das weiß nicht ob das
Sagen ersetzen oder können die die
Bedürfnisse genauso befriedigen wie zum
eine Frau das kann im Kern ist es
wichtig dass das Kind sich gebunden
fühlt und geborgen
erfüllt und das verlässlich jemand für
das Kind da ist der ihm Liebe gibt und
das muss nicht notwendigerweise eine
Frau sein und das muss auch nicht
notwendigerweise die biologische Mutter
sein ja jetzt ja im Endeffekt aber deine
professionelle Einschätzung darauf
beruht auf mein Gefühl zu hören wenn
dann klares Gefühl ist nein ich möchte
keine Kinder und das einzige was mich
davon abhält diesen Nein zu vertrauen
ist eventuell bereue ich das wenn ich 50
bin dann hilft es vielleicht auch sich
zu überlegen welche Gründe man damals
hatte sich dagegen zu entscheiden und
was man heute auch am Leben wie man es
jetzt lebt schätzt wenn es nach mir
gehen würde wäre es ja jetzt zeitnah
aber jetzt erst hat wirklich angefangen
dass ich beruflich einfach wirklich
immer mehr zu dem Ziel komme
wohin ich eigentlich schon seit Jahren
hin möchte ja ich will wissen einfach
nicht weiter und spricht denn für dich
was dagegen einfach ein bisschen später
Kinder zu kriegen das ist ja auch
gesellschaftlich ein ziemlich großer
Trend hin dazu dass man einfach das
Kinder kriegen auf die zweite Hälfte der
30er oder sogar auf die frühen 40er
verschiebt Angie Zweifel stark und für
mich kommt das Kinderkriegen gehört für
mich dazu ich bin da sehr sehr
aufgeschlossen
wie könnten wir uns denn annähern
pack deine Zweifel auf den Tisch ich
glaube das ist das gesündeste was ihr
machen könnt und sprecht offen darüber
ohne enttäuscht zu sein vom anderen ja
ohne Vorbehalte einfach jeder darf offen
sagen was im Bauchschmerzen macht ich
hoffe es hat euch ein bisschen geholfen
hat mehr geholfen super alles Gute
tschüss danke
ob ich Kinder will die Antwort ist auf
jeden Fall ja die Frage war aber wann
das ist ja auch schön zu hören das ist
eben man sich da auch auch hin
entwickeln kann und nicht
trefft die Entscheidung ja oder nein und
und das ist jetzt irreversibel oder so
sondern ja wir können das zusammen
vielleicht auch Einwachsen bei mir ist
es nach wie vor ja ich will Kinder ich
bin auch bestärkt worden in der
Leihmutterschaft es scheint doch für
mich die Alternative zu sein oder die
Möglichkeit zu sein die für mich passt
werden großes Glück wenn es tatsächlich
so kommen würde nach Hause ich glaube
auf der Zugfahrt nachher streichen wir
erstmal noch mal die Frauen
jetzt gerade würde ich sagen nein ich
will jetzt keine Kinder und auch morgen
wahrscheinlich auch nicht weil er auch
zum Ende des Jahres auch nicht
vielleicht auch nächstes Jahr noch nicht
ich denke vorher war ja die Tendenz
zwischen nein und vielleicht ich glaube
jetzt ist er bei vielleicht und das nein
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger geworden
aber so so ein klassisches ja oder nein
kann ich jetzt leider nicht geben ja
das wäre für mich kein Grund die
Beziehung zu beenden wenn wenn Angie
sich gegen Kinder entscheidet beantworte
lautet in drei fünf Jahren da musst du
noch ein bisschen warten zumindest habe
ich jetzt zahlen
[Musik]